There are some free stars in sight, and also I have the little white objects that seem to come from the capsule itself, and drift off.
And if they are a yard check, it's fantastic. I suspect that the star I see is of tourists would be very interesting.
It is neither. It is one of the white objects.
So now two stars are still quite still.
The one object I still look like it came toward me, but it wasn't.
You can actually see the particle that is flying off, and it is turned to scarred.
It is a wave and shaving. It is a very good description of it.
My rates are now just about two or over all three axes.
They still have white in the first open door, so I am looking straight up.
And yet, at this point, there is a tree that my object is.
I get the couch out. I really can't pick it too well, yeah.
Just about inverted at this point.
At the end of the point, nose is above the horizon.
As a result, I notice that these particles keep tending air to me, relative to me, at any time.
The first scope is blocking out of the rapidly, at sunset.
It is almost blocked out from briefly at this point, and it is really not useful.
It is a real burst of light in me.
Wind down, I really don't know what it is.
At this point, I should be coming up on a sunset by the last 15 minutes.
First scope is dark.
Unless you are just getting the last look at the horizon, get out of that down on it.